hey guys welcome back to brand new video
we are back on forun again today we have
some interesting news to talk about the
new cinematic reveal trailer for the new
hero vortigor or the black pryor i'm
still kind of confused on what the
actual name is
has just been released but we'll get
into that a little bit later on the
terms of the name
but anyway let's get started with
today's video as always like the video
if you do enjoy subscribe if you're new
i cover the informational side of 400
that being balance changes hero updates
patch notes and leaks
and all that stuff so if you want to be
kept up to date with everything
happening in for honor and in the world
of it
subscribe to the channel and with that
let's get started with this breakdown
first up if you go to the ubisoft
website it has a huge photo of the word
in the background called vordiger
and then with the character in the front
and it reads new for honor hero the
black prior coming january 31st
400 year three the year of the harbinger
is almost upon us and with it comes the
introduction of the new deadly hero the
black prior
the black priors are heavy heroes who
fight with a kite a giant kite shield
and longsword
once knights of the order from holy
balor the black pirates were born when
their leader vordiger was swayed by
apollyon's promises of power
with her defeat the order dispersed and
disappeared now the black pirates have
returned to fight for vordiger seeking
to make amends for their past and pledge
fealty to the knights
the black pirate will be available for
all year 3 pass holders on january 31st
while all other players will be able to
unlock the new hero on february 7th
for 15 000 steel so yeah this is the
part that has me a little bit confused
because
in the in the title of the video it says
for honor year three season one new hero
vordiger but then on the ubisoft website
it says new 400 hero the black prior
i'm still thinking it's going to be
vordiger because that's just a more
easier name to say than him saying black
prior maybe that's his type of class
or something like that like how warden
is considered a knight and stuff like
that
well vordiger is considered a black
prior stuff like that's what i'm
thinking it's gonna be
but that is not all actually underneath
that it says there is a lot more in
store for year three season one of for
honor
as the shugoky warlord and peacekeeper
will already be receiving hero updates
furthermore a new dominion map harbor
will be accessible for all 400 players
on january 31st for free
a port town on the shores of lake
evitrinen i totally ruined that name
harbor makes a key strategic location
that makes members of the black prior
ones help the knights defend against
their enemies
and it also states that full details on
everything about this season will be
revealed
next week on the devstream on the 24th
so be looking out on the channel on the
24th for that info
tomorrow is the 17th so we most likely
won't be getting that but i'm assuming
we will be getting executions tomorrow
so that's going to be exciting to see
but yeah as the name suggests we're
probably most likely going to be
fighting on a map near a bunch of ships
so that's pretty nice and it's also
dominion map so i cannot wait to play
this a lot more because the other map i
complete the secluded keep i believe was
the name not many people play that
because it's more of a dual
and elimination type game mode because
they didn't put it in dominion but going
off the trailer we have some pretty nice
details and stuff to look at
this guy gives me some type of arabian
or prince of persia type vibe
but this is because of the environment
and his choice of attire regardless he
is still part of the knight so he
clearly isn't any of these i'm just
pointing out some neat things i saw
here's a beautiful image of the sword
it's a straight sword that curves
towards the tip and what looks like a
face on the handle
looks incredible with all the engravings
on it as well crazy looking weapons for
this guy
you can also see the apollyon flag on
the side and this goes with the lore
that we talked about before
where vordiger pledged his allegiance to
apollyon for the promises of power
and his black prior knights joined
apollyon as well
but since she died they had nowhere else
to go so they ended up pledging to the
knights faction so that's a pretty nice
touch as well for the lore
around here you can get a really good
look at the shield since out in the open
and not in this dark cave where he's
chilling in
even more detail on this with spikes on
the sides a huge head in the middle
my thoughts are that these are going to
be part of a weapon set in the game
since they both have the head
piece somewhere on the weapon these you
could probably pair these up together if
you do want to rock the same shield and
sword
my only concern is that the weapon in
the teaser that we saw a couple weeks
ago and then in the cinematic trailer is
different
every season in the main menu comes up
with all the new heroes and next to them
is their weapon
in the default version i'll show the
marching fire background on screen right
now
in this photo all four of the wulin have
their weapons their default armor
and their default weapon coming up but
this is a little bit different
vordiger has this type of armor set but
in the teaser he has a big green
shield why is this different this could
be a cinematic touch or maybe
the the cinematic trailer has the
default gear and the teaser was a
variation or vice versa
who knows let me know your thoughts
because that confused the [ __ ] out of me
when i saw this because i'm trying to
think of like past
seasons and stuff like that and trying
to compare things yeah but let me know
what you guys think i'm super excited to
play the new vortiger hero or black
prior whatever the
[ __ ] his name is i'm still going with
vordiger until i'm ch until i'm told
otherwise by the developers
but i'm very excited to play this
character another sword in board hero
very similar to warlord because you know
the sword and board and whatnot but this
guy
he seems very beefy i cannot wait to
play him i feel like a lot of conqueror
players and especially warden players
are going to be
migrating over since it seems like a
very similar play style
and remember next week on the 24th of
january we are going to be seeing
gameplay of these characters so
definitely
stick stay tuned on the channel i'll
tell you guys all about the gameplay
next week as well as the possible
executions that might come out tomorrow
so let me know your thoughts let me know
your thoughts as well on the characters
receiving hero updates shugoki warlord
pk i don't really see why peacekeeper is
perceiving something
again but i understand why shugoke and
warlord are but anyway guys like the
beef and do enjoy subscribe if you're
new i cover the informational side of
400 that being balanced changes here
updates patch notes and leaks so if you
want to be kept updated with all the
news on
for honor then stay tuned to the channel
and with that guys my two most recent
videos will be on screen if you guys do
want to check that out hey guys hope you
have a great yesterday thank you for
watching the video
peace out enjoy the trailer
[Music]
you